Hey guys. Hey guys. Well, everybody knows who mine is. What is? Favorite candy. Didn't you just say favorite candies? No. Oh no.
You were just thinking that? Oh my God, Sean. He's hearing candy voices again. Are you thinking all the time favorite candies? I thought you just said name your favorite candy. No, nobody said favorite candies. Oh boy, welcome to Smartless. Smart.
Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart.
Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart. Lias. So, listener, Sean is in England. London, England. And what's Sean, what you're doing there,
this is the Edgar Wright. This is just a little cameo in the Running Man movie directed by Edgar Wright. You went to England to record some cameos? Uh-huh. Okay. Yeah, how much you got, how much you got? Okay, hey, it's Sean Hayes, happy birthday. Gary, how much you got how much you got? Okay. Hey, it's Sean Hayes. Happy birthday Gary
Congratulations Sean you've got a slide of London. Yeah, Sean you've negotiated a very nice accommodations for yourself there. Yes It's wonderful. Thanks good for you pictures. Yeah. Oh Lovely, so that's a at least a one-bedroom suite. You've got there for your cameo Oh, lovely, so that's at least a one bedroom suite you've got there for your cameo? Well, we get two bedrooms because there's snoring happening with Scotty. Oh, so you've come out of pocket is what you're saying.
You're gonna spend everything you're making just to keep Scotty out of your bed. You know, also, I know we talked about this before, but the jet lag thing, it is unbelievable. What time is it right now for you? It's 5.30 and like 20 minutes ago, my head was bobbing and like. Well yeah, cause it's 9.30 in the morning
here in Los Angeles. So you just have spent all night awake. Night up, right. Let's just say this, it's safe to say, and I mean this with a tremendous amount of love. Uh oh. Uh oh. You operate, your normal life is if you have jet lag.
It's totally terrible. It's terrible. You should be sent away to a sleep, I mean it. Because. No, I did it, I did a sleep study and all that. I have apnea and all that. Something needs to happen because you're a candidate for dropping dead.
What do you mean? Wait, are you saying because he's tired all the time? Well, he just has no, his. Well, I just sleep three or four hours and I'm up, then I sleep another three or four hours and I'm up. His sleep hygiene is, yeah, it's really bad. And I mean this, I know that I'm sort of joking around, but it is true that it's a, you know, it's serious.
No, I know, I know. But I tried, listen, I did the thing, I went to the, you know, got the sleep study, you know, and then they say, you have apnea, it's really bad, and they say, they sell you that machine, so I bought the machine, and I just, I tried it for a month, I just, there's so, I could talk for an hour about all the issues I have.
One thing I didn't tell you, Jason, I think I told. Wait, so are you still using the hoses? No, I'm done, I can't do it. Right, so now you're just risking, you're risking suffocating to death every night. Yeah, your health. Yeah, I sleep better without the machine. No, you don't.
I do, I'm telling you. All right. I can't, I can't, but there is something funny that happens with that machine. You know, you know what it is, right? You hook it up to your nose, your nostrils, it goes through your nostrils and it covers your mouth and blah, blah, blah.
And so I'm all set up and Scott, and Scottie comes in, this is like a few weeks ago, to say goodnight to me and I have it on so you can't really talk because all the air is blowing inside of your mouth. So he goes. Yeah, you're like in the ER. Yeah, just like in the ER. And he goes, all right, babe, I love you, goodnight.
And I go, I love you too. You can't take it out of your mouth. Is it? I love you too. But you're now Scotty's real, I mean, you're already his dream guy, but now you're his real, because now you've got a whole sci-fi look to you. You're scratching every inch of his.
I look like Prometheus, the guy in Prometheus. Oh, God. So now does that get him excited? Are you guys, are you having an increased physical life or an increased one? No, God, just the opposite. Yeah. We're into sort of just like a seasonal touch up. Yeah, what do you mean?
It's like once in the spring, once in the winter, once in the fall. You want to know the rates of their sex life? I do, I do, mean? It's like once in the spring, once in the winter, once in the fall. You want to know the rates of their sex life? I do, I do, let's do that. I'm sure our guest will wait. Let's do that. I like hearing, we get updates from Amanda when you guys do it.
Yeah, right? Oh yeah, unsolicited. And then Jason, I'm like, hey Amanda, honestly, you got to know that I don't want to know this. Yeah, don't want to know about anybody, unsolicited. And then Jason, I'm like hey, Amanda, honestly, you gotta know that I don't wanna know this. Yeah, don't wanna know about anybody, by the way. Yeah. Oh, she loves to share. I know.
It's sweet. God bless her. It is sweet. Will, thanks for combing your hair. It started a little bit rough. It's just sweaty, I just worked out. You don't need to scream, okay? We're all exercising, all right? Okay. Fuck. You don't need to scream, okay, we're all exercising. All right?
Fuck. What are you doing for workouts over there in New York? Are you outside or are you inside? No, no, no, I'm inside. I'm mixing it up. I've got a few different things that I'm doing and Downey put me in touch with these guys who've opened a new facility
that I'm going to go look at next week that apparently they do all sorts of cool stuff. Oh really? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And I'm in touch with a guy and I just haven't had it. What kind of new stuff? Like stuff we don't know about? Yeah, just like new stuff.
Like how to kill a guy with a ballpoint pen. Well that, yeah, it's just more like street fighting. You know. But you get hot looking while you're doing it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. All right, are you guys ready? Yeah. I mean I guess so.
Do you have a whole intro? Well, our next guest grew up in England, okay? Oh, okay. But you know what, she's a real whippersnapper. She's, this 20-year-old has already done a lot. What? Yeah. What?
She's received multiple nominations for Emmys and SAG. She's produced and starred in her own franchise. She's written a New York Times bestseller, now being adapted for the screen by an Oscar nominee. She's got her own global beauty product line. She's a star of one of the most successful shows in the world and still at just 20 years old, she's the proud mother of 10 children.
What are you talking about? They all have four legs. It's all one of his weird intros. Go ahead. Who is it? Yeah, they've all got four legs, but she doesn't love them any less. Oh my God. Guys, please welcome Miss Millie Bobby Brown.
No way! You guys. No way! Oh my God. You guys, it's very hard to stay quiet while you're taking the piss out of each other. It's really hard. Now, Millie... Millie, it's not Millie Bobbs signing, right?
It's Millie. Yeah, Millie. And we're not doing... Are we doing the Bon Giovi as well? You did take his name. Yes, I am, like legally. But like stage names saying the same. So how are you introducing yourself?
Hi, my name is. When we sue you. Yeah, we want to get it right. It'll be Millie Bobby Bon Jovi if you sue me. Okay, what do you mean if? Now Will, you're fairly close to her father-in-law, is that correct? I want to say fairly close,
I've known him for a number of years. Yeah, he's a great dude. The best. A great dude, a past guest of the show here. Past guest of the show, great guy. Yeah, yeah, we've had John on here. He's a great musician, talented guy, great guy. What kind of father-in-law is he? Fantastic.
Busy? Yeah, like it's been so great because I grew up, obviously, in the public eye and he started, you know, so young, like, so it was, it's really nice because he, you know, obviously us being, he's a man and I'm a woman, so we deal with our separate things, but to be able to come together sometimes and when I need him,
he is very much there for me in like the best ways, like always like making sure I need him, he is very much there for me in the best ways, always making sure I'm okay, if there's anything that's ever going on, I'm always like, can you help me out in this situation? And he's just so informative. Talking about the weirdness of the business, yeah. I mean, just, yeah, it's like, his wisdom is ridiculous. Not a lot he hasn't been through. Yeah, and just like, but also such a great person,
so for me it's like, yeah, we talk about the whole fame thing, but it doesn't really come up in conversation. It's more about like the kind of person he and his, like his wife, my mother-in-law is. Like they are just, they're just really good people. And like they just do good and they're good people. And so I just strive to be like them. Yeah, I like that. They're like, they're like, really, really admirably normal people. Well, yeah, like, which is, you know, yeah. But also they did everything together, like,
which is so beautiful, like everything, they, they, they start their high school sweethearts, so to be able to go through that all together as a team, they make such a wonderful team, such great parents, obviously, they're four kids. Yeah, Dorothea, right? That's his wife, she's amazing, she's really cool.
She really is, so I've been really lucky. Like, never, you know, I have, my parents are English. Your dad's amazing, please tell him hello. Love that guy. You know he loves you so much. Wait, how do you know her dad, Jason? You guys, easy, don't worry about it, okay? Wait, wait, wait, Millie. How do you how does your dad know Jason? Going to the I'm asking her not you we were at an award show party my dad like of course
That's where you'll find them. That's where you find my father apparently. No, it's oh Jason oh no, Jason. You were I you were... I've got a catering company. Never mind. No, I think there was... They just deliver nuts. I think you... I want to say you were nominated. Something like that.
We were... That doesn't sound right. And I was too, I think. So we were together at this party and my dad never does this. He came up to me, he's like, do you think that you could go up to Jason Bateman for me? Because I love him. And I was like...
I was like 14. I was like, sure. So I go up and walk over and I'm like, hi! Like, this is my dad. And anyway, my dad is like the sweetest person, but he is, and he's so personable, so funny, he's so English, like you would know. He would be, the banter is endless with him, and so he kind of just makes friends with really anyone.
Like he, yeah, I mean he's really great. Like he got a coconut cake from Tom Cruise this year. Like, do you know what I mean? Like, he's just that kind of guy. Like, makes friends with everyone, loves everyone, and you just happen to be one of his favorite people. And yeah, that's kind of like... Up until he met him.
Up until, yeah. Of course, and then he said, wow, never meet your idols. Now, since you started so young, he must have been on set with you a bunch, and then once you passed 18, now you no longer get to share full days with him. Because I remember that transition in my life
with my parents, it's like you miss them a bit, yeah? Yeah, well, it's really interesting because when I turned 18, it was just really weird, like, well, what do we do now? And do you still want to come? When I turned 18, it was this really weird, what do we do now? And do you still want to come? Because it's also like, you know. I can drive now, Dad.
Yeah, and also just like, I know it's boring. I know what you're doing is like, it's sat there boring. But he now is just my manager and we do everything together. We sign deals together, figure out my next everything together. helps me run my production company. We are developing new stories every day. He's a very creative man. He usually follows me everywhere. We have separation anxiety and he is the worst for it. He doesn't like to admit it, but he really is.
So anytime I'm not in England, they'll basically follow me around. This is the longest time, and he'll get out his calendar in his office and he'll be like, not with Millie, not with Millie. And he's like, okay, I'm not with you for three weeks. Like, what are we going to do? I'm going to be like that.
That's going to be hard for me when my girls leave. What do you mean? Well, when they go to college, you know, because I like my daughters. Don't look so confused. Sorry, no, I'm really, this is news to all of us. Sorry, Millie. Yeah, their names are...
There we go. Hey, Millie, how old were you? We know JB, I know JB is like, you've been worrying about them going to college since they were eight. I know, it's true. You're the first guy whose kids have gone away. Shut up, Bateman.
Hey, Millie, can I ask you a question? He has been, he's been like teary-eyed for 10 years. I know, it's very true. Millie, how old were you? What was your first foray into performing, like whose idea was it? Was it your mom and dad going like, all right, we've got a real hot ticket on our hands here, we need to put her into something?
Or were you like, I gotta go do something? Like, what was that process? No, my parents are like, you know, my dad worked on a fruit and veg stand. Like he worked at a market, a fruit and vegetable market. So my dad did that the majority of his life. And that goes back, like actually we have pictures of our family in like the 1800s,
like doing that same thing. No kidding? Yeah, so it's like florist. What part of the UK was that in? In Dorset, so in the countryside of England. Okay, nice. And so that's what my dad did. My mom, she had four kids.
She had her last daughter when she was 41. So she's been the best, most present mom ever and been very lucky to have that time with her. Where are you in that order? I'm third. Third, okay. So my older sister's 30. My older brother is 27. And then my younger sister's 30, my older brother is 27,
and then my younger sister is 13. Wow, amazing. Yeah, they had gaps, it was really weird. And yeah, so basically I... JB, you have a gap, right? Like 88 to 92, is that a big gap for you? Oh, I thought you had this one between my teeth, I can whistle with it.
I remember you saying 88 to 92 is a big gap for you? Oh, I thought you had this one. This one between my teeth. I can whistle with it. No, 88 to, I remember you said, 88 to 92 is a big gap for you. Yeah. So there you are. You're in the UK. Your dad's working selling fruit and veg. Amazing. Yeah. And I've always been,
I always loved dancing and singing. Like, it was not, like, acting, I didn't really even know it was a job. Like, I didn't know it existed. And then we moved to Orlando, Florida from England, kind of randomly. Really? Not for you, not for performance?
No, just because my family, I would like to say, and even now we're still very like, we're nomads. Like we kind of just, if we never take a plane, we always drive. We're always just like that kind of family. If we want to go somewhere, we'll just get in the car and go. We've always been like that, never kind of, we don't need a lot to plan.
Her dad was in search of a better orange, and took him right to Orlando. Really nice connection. And then you thought, what's up? That was a really great, I just, that took so much longer for me in my head. I'm so sad. I was like, I was like, what? Oh, I'm sad too, but for different reasons.
Hey, so Orlando, you guys were like, hey, what's the most beautiful, idyllic city in the world? We went, no, no, no, no. We went to, we went there a lot as like, growing up I went there a lot on vacation. And then my dad was like, I love, I just love it here. I love the weather, I love the vibe, I love the people. So we were like, okay, so we moved there
for about maybe six, eight months, and then. How old were you when you moved? I was eight. Wow. Wow. And my little sister was probably like, oh my gosh, maybe like, I want to say like nine weeks old. Like, it was like, she was really, it was kind of a crazy decision, but we moved.
And then I went to school in Orlando, again, not performing at this point. And then on like, we heard this thing on the radio, me and my dad, and it was like, come to this workshop where you can dance, sing and act. And da da da. My dad was like, that's cool, you should go. Because I was driving him insane on the weekends,
basically just keep me busy. I didn't have any friends or anything. Singing and dancing. Yeah. And then he took me and then I started going for a bit and then I came back home and I was like, you need to take me, I actually said, which I don't remember saying this,
but my parents are like, you said it. I said, if you take me to Hollywood, I'll make it. And my dad was like, what do you mean? And I was like, I want to go to Hollywood. And I remember having like, I wanted so badly to be in LA and to be an actor. And so the next week, we packed up the car and we drove from Orlando to LA.
We didn't have a house, we didn't have anything planned. We stayed in a motel on the side of the highway. What? And I just went to auditions and agents the whole time. And were your siblings like, I don't want to go to Hollywood. I want to stay. Well, you know what's crazy is, no, my brother didn't like school in America.
He had a hard time adjusting because he was like 16, so it was a little harder for him. I found it even difficult, like making friends there, just being able to kind of have common ground, especially when you're 60. All these people know each other. They all go to the same kindergarten, the same, you know what I mean?
And they all know each other. And this is a small town in Florida. So for my brother, I know it was hard for him to adjust. And then- But what was the plan for mom and dad to do in Hollywood? While they, and the other kids, you guys just loaded up the van and went across the country and we'll just figure it out when we get there?
Yeah, pretty much. It was like, we'll figure it out. Great family. I mean, incredible. It's amazing. Figure it out, and like everything was like, if we're together, we're okay. Like, we're always going to be okay.
Right, no matter what. And then you crushed it. And did your parents have jobs lined up along the way? So, no, like my dad, my dad actually, because I was born in Spain, which is- Marbella. Marbella. And so my dad was a really successful real estate agent
there, that's what he got into. So he was always like, my dad again, he's kind of a jack of all trades, always been kind of knowing of everything, and it's always been his very talented in that. So when we moved there, it was literally, it was like we have to kind of, now we have to figure this out.
So I went on auditions and- You got an agent right away that got to the auditions? Got an agent. I actually weirdly, maybe the first two weeks, I was going to agents and went to a bunch of different people and I went to Mel's Drive-In for lunch. And James Woods was there. Yeah, okay.
And he was like, and I grew up watching, like I didn't watch animation. Like I watched Casino, I watched Moulin Rouge, I watched like these were like, I never ever believed, like I was never one of those kids. Right, right. I loved Disney Channel. You knew who he was.
But I did know who he was. He wrote on like the, like, you know, I knew you before you were famous, and it was like the two weeks that I got to LA, and I kind of, I got an agent and did the whole thing. Then I basically just auditioned after, and I was going up for jobs, like, you know, I went for commercials,
but I also went for the BFG, I went, you know, I did Steve Jobs, like the Jobs movie. Like I really went up for everything and got really close. I mean, yeah, like I kind of was... With no training. No, no, I've never, never been trained. Like even when I was going in Orlando, it was never training. like it was always like, do you know what I mean?
It was like, they taught me how to sing, they taught me how to model, which was terrible, like I am not a model. And then they taught me how to dance and I loved it, but of course it was like me like just shaking ass, like had no idea what I was doing. Right, right, right. But the acting thing, I really got,
I could, you know, the monologue stuck in my head and I would think about it for a while. And like, that stuck for me. Right. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Well, what's so amazing to me is, first of all, nerd alert. Like, the rest of the world, I'm such a huge Stranger Things fan.
And when I watched the first season, I mean, I was just blown away, not only by the show, but of course by you, and I had that thought. I was like, how does this little girl know how to be such a brilliant actor? Without even speaking that much, right? I mean, that first season, there wasn't. That's why I said no training,
because it's like, how are you A, so comfortable in front of the camera, B, how did you learn how to do that at such a young age when it takes years and years for other people to do it? Yeah, she's so young and so much better than you already. Like that must have been for you jarring. What the hell is going on? It was very jarring.
And then I read for one of the kids as well, on Stranger Things. No, I, I, I, I, I'll be honest, like, you know, when, when we started, like I started auditioning and I got like jobs, like I was like, you know, did NCIS and Modern Family and like, I was kind of just doing these like bit roles, but like still had just so much fun. But when we moved back to London because we eventually couldn't afford
to live in LA anymore and like we couldn't we basically was just like we can't do this anymore. So we moved back to London and then I had an audition where I got told like basically I wasn't going to make it. And like in person, this person told me this. Wait, wait, wait, who is the person, you don't have to say their name, but what was their position? They were a casting director.
How old were you at the time? Maybe, gosh, 10. Imagine saying that to a 10 year old. This monster said to you, you know you're not going to make it as an actor. That I was too mature, so I couldn't, I wasn't going to make it because I was too mature. I didn't have that kid-like kind of, that kid-like thing, right? And so I went home and I cried and I cried and I said I'm not going to do it anymore.
Like I don't want to act anymore. My parents were like, my parents, my dad actually. My mom was very much always like, whatever you want, we love ya. You know what I mean? But my dad, he always, Your accent is actually not too bad. Thank you, yeah thank you.
But yeah, my dad saw something, he always saw that drive in me and was like never letting, like would never let me, you know, slip on that and so he was like, there's this audition in my inbox, let's do the last one and then we're done, like we don't have to do it anymore. And that last audition was Stranger Things. Wow. And so you auditioned from, in England?
On that same day. I was so upset from what happened. On the same day? It was the upset from what happened. On the same day? It was the same day and my dad just like, we set it up and I just went on a blank wall, read the script and was like, what? Like she doesn't have any lines. She just cries.
And she bleeds from her nose. Yeah, but it didn't even say anything. It didn't say like she had superpowers, her name was Levin, nothing like that. It was just like girl, confused, like comes to, doesn't seem like she's kind of human. Like very, very, and I was really vague and I just did what felt natural
but also used so much of the emotion that had been happening earlier on in that day. Yeah, you were in a really raw place. Really raw, like my, yeah. And did you have long hair then and then of course you shaved it for the first season. Yeah, yeah. I had long hair then? And then of course you shaved for the first season. Yeah. I had long hair and then didn't hear from them for three months
and kind of stopped auditioning. Like didn't audition three months and then I got an email saying, hey, you know, the directors of that show that you auditioned for really like you. Can we face... Can we Skype? So... Remember that, guys? I Skyped with them. I Skyped with them. I Skyped with them, yeah I know.
I said that the other day and people younger than me were like, I don't know what you're talking about. And I was like, boom. It used to be like, yo, can I Skype you real quick? Do you remember that? Yeah. Sorry, go ahead. So you did a call back video, yeah.
Yeah, and I did an American accent the whole time because I didn't want them to know I was British. So they had no idea I was British. I basically wanted them to know that I could hold an American accent for that long without them knowing so they could rely on me. So then after the Skype, they were like, can you fly out to LA?
So my dad and I flew out to LA. And this is kind of the weird part. And I said this in my speech on the last day of filming, but we got on the plane and at this point I knew that my character's name was Eleven and I was on row Eleven. And then we got to the hotel, I was on floor Eleven. And everything just seemed really, really weird.
Everything felt way too real and kind of positive and optimistic for the first time in kind of like years. And then I went in and I met with them, and I remember it was really weird. They didn't have any lines for me, they just were like, here's a box of clothes. What would you do if you weren't human, if you didn't know who you are,
you weren't a normal regular girl, what would you do with this? And I just kept putting the clothes on my head and then just kind of feeling them and I think they were like, shit. She's crazy. We found her. Oh, sorry. Oh, sorry, we found her. Oh, sorry.
Oh, sorry, we found her, yeah. That too, they didn't realize that then, but I think they do now. You probably had Sean Levy saying, well, she's wrinkling those clothes. What is she doing with them? But what would you do if you took these clothes? The great Sean Levy.
You're so lucky you had him shepherding the whole thing. Don't interrupt my Sean Levy impression. The greatest guy. It was very good, it was very good. How lucky you had him shepherding the whole thing. Don't interrupt my Sean Levy impression. Greatest guy. It was very good, it was very good. And then the next day I got a call in the hotel room as I was leaving back to Heathrow. And then it was the directors and they said,
do you want to be our 11 and can you shave your hair off? And I was like, yes and yes. And then literally three months later I was shaving my hair off. That's crazy. Wow. By the way, we've all had those moments. We've all had people say stuff to us in our career where they go, you're not right, you're
never going to be right, or you're not going to... All that kind of stuff. His name is Scotty. But to say... Yeah, and Scotty says that a lot too. And rightfully so. You've got very little talent. But what is particularly repulsive is when an adult says
that to a 10 year old, and I know it's a professional environment, but in that moment to think that it's okay to say something like that to a 10 year old, to me is absolutely way out of bounds, I think. You know what though, I just feel like growing, like even growing, like that to me, doesn't even like really scrape the surface. Like it's like, growing up in the industry,
I, you know, it can get like that. People see you as an adult. And because you- They forget that you're a kid, because you're coming in- Well you're hired, you're hired. So in. Well, you're hired, you're hired. So you're like, you're hired like an adult. You don't work the hours as an adult,
but you're expected to be there like an adult. Like you're expected to do the job. You're expected, yeah, same responsibilities. Like pretty much everything is the same, you know, except you got to do school three hours a day, really, like that's really it. And so I was so lucky because for me, and I guess that maturity really paid off,
because I was really able to understand the weight of what I was doing, so I was never like, yippity-do-da, what am I doing next? I was always very like, okay, I have my cool time is tomorrow, I need to get eight hours. I was so strict with myself. My parents were always like, they always kind of knew I was like that too, I loved school,
would really prioritize school. I was just kind of annoyingly one of those kids that just loved work, loved school, just loved really being on set. I was so excited to be done with school so I could have more hours at work because I just loved it. I love that. You know what I noticed, by the way,
this is, hopefully you don't think this is something bad, but like I've noticed. Here we go. You're in the States right now, United States? My accent. Yes, I was just going to say, you go in and out. It's really cool, actually.
Well, because you spent a lot of time here and spent a lot of time there. That was such a huge thing for a minute. My whole, I actually call it the accent gate, because it's so frustrating, because that was everywhere. For a second, everyone was talking about my accent, and they had a real problem about it. And I was like, guys, I'm married to an American.
When I'm around his family, I immediately go into an American accent. But then I was just in England and then the second I hear my mom and dad's accent, I just go right back into it. It's really cool. And I'm like, you want me to be an actor, you want me to play these characters,
but you expect me not to morph into people. What I hear is what I do, I do that, you know? And it's like, it's all part of it. And I'm just like, on my own. Wherever you are, you're going to be influenced by your location. Just like you are. You're doing it right now, Will.
Yeah, of course. With your English accent. Sean's about to move onto Old Queen Road, and then he's going to morph into that. So like everybody. There's a nice flat over there. I'm really eyeing. What are you doing, dude?
What are you doing? Millie, if so, closing the loop on the childhood start thing, what would you say to that 10 year old starting out now, now that you know a lot since then, what do you think you could say to that 10 year old that would help her kind of cut some corners?
You know, like, I'll be honest, like I really think that like I am so glad like everything happened to me. Like even the shitty stuff that I know kind of was hard at the time that I was going through, like I needed to go through it. Like, because I really am am a different person from it. And I know it sounds silly, but I started this when I was eight years old, and I'm turning
21 next week. And I- Same. Happy birthday. Same. Thank you. We're all 21. We're all turning 21.
Yeah, like to Jason, looking back now, what is the one thing or several things that you wish you knew that you wish you knew like that that you go You know what happened to me when I was 11 or 12 or 13 or 14 I'm gonna make sure that never happens again Yeah, I didn't need to worry about this as much or conversely to think so you don't focus on a negative I wish there was something that I did more of. You know what I mean? Right, yeah, no, totally. I think for me, honestly, the only thing I would say to her
is like, your parents, you're good. Like, don't worry. Like, they got you. No matter what. Lean into that as much as possible. Because when you're a kid, you try and, you know, you want to do everything on your own, and you're trying your best. But like, no. I am so reliant on my family.
And like, honestly, they have kept my feet on the ground. And I just would probably say to them, or say to her, because I know she was maybe a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more my feet on the ground and I just would probably say, or say to her that like, because I know she was maybe a little bit scared about growing up and making sure that- Well she's going to be scared that you're there
in the first place because you're appearing out of nowhere as your older self. That's true, she would be terrified. Give her a little space, okay? But no, what I was like, I feel like... She's got to absorb all that. I feel like, I feel like what's cool though, is that when I was younger, I was so afraid
of becoming those infamous child stars that just go awry. Jason Beatty. Right, those, exactly, Jason. That's a huge story that I know is viral. Yeah, cautionary tale, we call him. Exactly. No, but you know, and it's a deep fear because it happens. And by the way, you're constantly reminded of it in an interview. At like 12, 13 years old, people would be like,
what do you think about this person and their journey? Do you feel like you can relate to that? And trying to trick me, and I would go home and think, what if that happened to me? What if I lost touch of reality and that's so scary? And it really was a deep fear and honestly, I just again would tell myself, you're not going to be like that.
You have your family to guide you. Yeah, just anchor yourself into your family, into the things that matter, into your values. Yeah, but everything else I think I'm so grateful I went through. It's all great. Yeah, you know, and you would, I know that there are some things
I wish I could maybe change and stuff, but honestly, like, I'm happy I went through it, and like now I can just use that as reference. You know what, I'm just remembering, we met when you were a kid. We were at some thing, do you remember this? You were like, you had just started doing stranger met when you were a kid. We were at some thing. Do you remember this? You were like, you had just started doing stranger things.
You were like 12, you were with your mom and we were at like some event. Yeah, guess what, Will? She's got no idea what you're talking about. I know, she doesn't. Hey, no, no, no, I will say this, and actually it's so interesting because Ariana Grande, I think, just talks about it.
But like, I feel that I can't remember a lot of my childhood. Especially when Will Arnett's a part of it. You know, she starts like a, like a dial tone. Where were we? I don't know. It was at some, like at some professional engagement. But I, but you know. Because out of the gate,
Stranger Things was such, so massive. It was overnight. Right away. And I'm sure, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but I'm sure all of that, then you get all this attention, everybody wanting to do interviews and people meeting people, it just becomes a whirlwind and foggy. Yeah, sometimes people will say things to me and I'm like,
oh yeah, I did meet that person. I forget who I met. Yeah, you can't remember it all. I'm forgettable, I'm very forgettable, I will give you that. No, no, no, no, but seriously, I forget who I've met. Yeah, you can't remember at all. I'm forgettable. I'm very forgettable. I will give you that. No, no, no, no. But like, seriously, like, I... And like, I know people forget things when they're like, you know, older because they have kids, like, or when they're a kid, they forget things. But I...
Jason doesn't remember who we are. I'm the worst. But I think you're right, Sean. Like, I definitely, you right, Sholan. I went on a vacation right before Stranger Things came out and I had 25 followers and I don't even remember what my fucking username was. I didn't even really know what Instagram was. And then the next night, so we were driving to,
I think Palm Springs or something, and then I woke up from the nap, and I woke up and I had a million followers. My phone broke, and I looked at my dad and he was driving, I was like, what happened? And he's like, I think this show is going to be really, really big. And I was like, wow. And I remember I turned my phone, I was asking my mom, can you turn this off? I don't know how to even work this. And we got to the Palm Springs Hotel, to which the whole staff started freaking out,
because I still had a shaved head, and I still looked like 11. And people were freaking out, and I was like, oh my God. So it was actually over the course of a drive. 63 million followers. You have 63 million followers? Wow.
On what platform? Instagram. Is that Instagram? On Instagram, I think. Good Lord. Wow. You're looking good. Looks nothing like what I'm showing right now.
No, but wow, you look amazing. Thank you. That's insane. Well now, so then growing up with all of these sort of interesting pressures, to put it kindly, as Stranger Things was exploding, was it helpful to have other kids on the show? That you guys could sort of go through that together.
And now that it's over, is there a, how do you, that's like, those are brothers of yours that you have to like say goodbye to? Like, is it strange? Is it hard? It is strange. I think, you know, I'll be honest, like, you know, the kids, because there's so many boys, they, it was so great, because I know that they had such great camaraderie in their kind of brotherhood of growing up and being teen boys, you know, in this huge hit show.
For me, my journey was a little bit different. Like, you know, I feel like as a woman and as a young girl, I just went through it a bit differently in terms of the things that I was wearing and the kinds of things I was kind of not- Interested in. Subject to experiencing, but just a bit more, people would ask me very different questions than they would ask them. That's the way it felt.
It was very much like they could just be them and I kind of had to put some, like put a show on a little bit more. Right, right, yeah. Which was just a bit, it was just my different experience. But again, not like a bad experience, but just different. And I was, I am so close with the boys. Like I love them and I have been really lucky, again,
to have that experience with them and saying goodbye to them was really, really emotional. For all of us. Yeah, I saw that last day on the set. I almost started crying. It was incredible. Your speech was great. Thank you.
It was a lot longer than what I put on Instagram but I really wanted to, you know, I love the boys and I love the cast but the crew, like, I grew up with these people, and most of them were like my parents. Now what about, let's get to David Harbour. I'm about to start a project with David Harbour. Any hints, any tips, anything to get ready to enjoy,
anything to watch out for? It's just you and I talking. Here we go. David, so David and I, he played my dad in the show and like, he and I had, I would say, I would honestly say this, the most real relationship. Yeah, yeah. Like.
I hear he's fantastic. He and I had like a really, really transparent relationship where we're very, very honest, can be brutal with each other, but really good friends. And I think what is so amazing about him, he, everything's about your heart. He sees your heart, he knows what you want,
he wants to find the beauty in everything, and the beauty in the scene, and he wants to find it and he always Gave me that black look with JB I'm all heart good. Good luck. I'm finding any beauty in that heart We'll be right back All right back to the show You know, it's so amazing. I'm sorry, at the beginning you said Millie or Millie Bobby?
Millie. You can call me Mill. Whatever you want. You got to call her Millie Bobby Brown. I think you have to do the full. Miss Brown. And then Bon Jovi. Miss Brown.
And then Bon Jovi. What's really cool is that a lot of people with your success at such an early age would probably feel like, great, I did it, now I don't have to, whatever, I can rest on my laurels and whatever. But you just keep going with incredible work and, like Jason said, at the beginning with this new line of products that you have and it's really impressive that you still have a drive and a curiosity and a purpose. Have you got a big movie coming out this year too?
Don't you have a big movie coming out? Oh, yes. Let's talk about electric. State. State. Oh, yeah, and Pratt's in that too, right? Yes. Yes.
And then you have those upstart directors, the Russo brothers, I believe. I know. Like, oh, how did you get through that? Oh, these guys. I was terrible. These fucking guys. These guys.
No, I honestly like, you know, I walked onto that set and it's like a well-oiled machine. They, it's like. Yeah, I mean. And then that Pratt guy. No, I mean, Pratt's a different story. Pratt is like, I don't even under... His thing, which I love, is like, he always says, and I love this, he'll go like, if you come to set in a bad mood, what are you, having a hard time living your dream?
And I'm always like, I love that. He comes to set and he is truly so grateful and honored to be there and to fulfill that role. And he taught me a lot, because I love, listen, I love work, but you know, you go through your days where you're like, for fuck's sake, I'm having a bad day. But he saw, and he brought sun every day, it was always positivity, it was always funny, it was always like, just sun,
and the Russos also are so great at that, like keeping such a great spirited set. I saw the movie, it's really good. Thank you. Yeah, I loved it. Thank you, I loved, yeah, I mean the movie, like immediately I was so excited to do it, because I had never done anything like this,
and also my dream was to work with the Russo brothers, so like I, you know. What did Joe Russo call you? You know he calls everybody by their last name, or he'll go like hey, hey Brad Go sit down here and then move to the did he call you Brown? He didn't he calls me Mills. That's it Like he sometimes he doesn't even bother to get up out of his chair He'll just go feel I love when he does that so he'll be like, you know what once he said to me
I come into his tent and I'm like, hey guys, did you, his tent. And I'll be like, hey, did you see that? And he's like, yeah. And then he goes, we're getting cannolis. If you do this take, you get a cannoli. And I was just like, fuck yeah. And I, because he's so Italian. And I just remember, like, he gets his assistant, their assistant comes in with just like basically a box of cannolis and everyone's so Italian. And I just remember like he gets like his assistant,
their assistant comes in with just like basically a box of cannolis and everyone's just eating. His name is Anthony. No, not Ant. No, Anthony. Not Ant. Ant. Ant, hey Ant.
By the way, you go in there and you'd be like, hey Joe, what are you thinking? He's like, hang on a second, I'm just doing my fantasy football. I'm like, what? Yeah, Joe's doing his fantasy lineup and Anthony's actually running shit. No, no, on a second, I'm just doing my fantasy football. I'm like, what? No. Joe's doing his fantasy lineup and Anthony's actually running shit. No, no, on Electric State, he was addicted to TikTok
and we actually had to have a sit down talk about it. Of course he was. Did you teach him any dances? No, I don't have TikTok. I do not like TikTok, so I am not a fan of TikTok. So I, cause I just don't do this. Interesting, interesting. Walk me through that a little bit.
We've made some news right there. I just, I have a hard time with social media. I don't like social media. Thank you. Which is actually bringing it back. Says the girl with 63 million followers. It's not her fault they follow her. I don't have Instagram.
I don't have Instagram on my phone. Someone else does it for me. And I'll take a picture and then I'll send it to someone and then they'll post it for me. I love this. I think that's really healthy. I think that, you know, I've been a proponent of everybody taking a pause on social media.
I think it's really dangerous. But, and I think it's really good for you. But I'm not like, it's not like just TikTok. Like TikTok, I think, is a platform where I see, I used to see more negative than I did positive. So I was like, okay, I'm out. I don't want to be a part of that. So I felt the same thing with Instagram, so I did positive. So I was like, okay, I'm out. I don't want to be a part of that. So I felt the same thing with Instagram,
so I deleted that. So now I have no social media on my phone, so I don't get notifications about what's happening in the world, who's dating who. Who's you know. And I just don't enjoy it, so I am out of the loop. But. However, Joe.
He's not. Has a problem. He's not, he had a problem, and I had to bring it up to him. He knew that his scrolling for hours was becoming a huge issue and his algorithm was so weird. Like his like. Would he forget to yell cut?
No, never that bad. But like, it was like, I would like, we would be setting up a shot and he's just like in there, in his amazing chair that I'm just scrolling away Chuckling to himself and I was just like Anthony's out there setting frames Yeah, Anthony's not more responsible than Joe Joe's just rolling Shopping for a wheelchair so he doesn't ever have to stand up All right, let's get back into this interview
Millie you've got so much going on. I want to talk about the children. I want to talk about your 10 children. What are their names? So, okay, so basically I have Bobby, Marley, Max, Winnie, Agnes, Rigby, Pookie, Juno. Did I say Dorothy yet? No. Nope, Dorothy and I say Dorothy yet? No.
Nope, Dorothy, and I'm missing one, Jimmy. Sweet Jimmy. So I have 10 dogs, but then I have- But you've got a couple of turtles and a donkey. So I have, so I live on a farm, so I take care of, I have a horse, four ponies, two cows, five goats, yeah, I mean. Are you in the UK?
I'm in Georgia. Oh, wow. Come on. Wait, but did the dogs, did the 10 dogs stay in the house or out of the house? Yeah, so the 10 dogs are in the house, and then I have, so I have the farm animals, but the farm animals, I didn't,
I only got farm animals, really, I only got a donkey, because I had a coyote problem, and coyotes are terrified of donkeys. Wow. Is that right? Mm-hmm, so I got a donkey. Then I basically started rescuing farm animals. So basically, there would be a farm, and here in Georgia, there's goats on the side of the street,
and you're like, what the hell, who can take these? And I would just basically take these animals, and then I bottle-fed them. And I would just basically take these animals and then I bottle fed them. So I would bottle feed these farm animals. A goat came onto set of Electric State every day. I had to bottle feed my goat Eminem for every four hours. Like the candy or the rapper? The rapper, because he's the goat.
Hence the name. Love it. Stupid Will. Okay, sorry. I want to get back, can we just get back for one second to the donkeys are some sort of a coyote. The Terran. Now is that true?
Cause you know we've got massive coyote issues here in Los Angeles. It is true. That's why people, well that's why people often ask Sean to come over cause they recognize what a jackass he is. Hell. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. What about horses?
Are the coyotes, they don't care about the horses? No. It's a donkey. It is a donkey. A donkey, they actually are quite aggressive, which sounds kind of weird, but if a donkey like saw a dog, the donkey would try and kill the dog. It is a very, very much like, if you Google it, like you will see that like donkeys are very serious.
I'm going down, I'm going to get on a YouTube wormhole here and watch donkey fights with dogs. I think Arnold has a donkey. He does, he does. He does, right? Yeah. Who does? Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Yeah, I think. Schwarzenegger's got a donkey? Yeah, he has it in the house. Yeah. Yeah, but Jake had to kind of drill the line at some point because we were bringing in these goats that sleep in our bed and they're in diapers. What?
What? You got a diapered goat in the bed? Yeah, they sleep with me at night because I have to take care of, because they're babies. Girl, you so crazy. They're, they were basically babies and so I would sleep with them, and Jake, they would be in the middle, and they are so cute, and I basically,
Jake would get up and do a shift, and then I would get up and do a shift. Yeah, she would do that actually. I had it, I had like Norman, Lammy, Eminem, I did the same thing with my cows. But they would wear a diaper in the bed with you. You've got to lose yourself, you own it, the moment you never get it back.
Ha ha ha ha. It's so stupid, dumb, and cheap, you're fired. Millie, please continue. That was, I liked that a lot. Wait, but you would have to change their diapers and all that stuff. Yeah, well, and then people started, in my community, people started thinking I was pregnant
because I was buying bottles and nappies and all the things. Yeah. So then they reach around like eight weeks old and then they're full grown and they have horns and they're they're wanting to go outside so then I have them outside and then we put them outside and then It's not a good combo horny in a diaper Speaking of Scotty do you think All right, so then they're outside and then you move on to another baby animal in the bed Ah, what a, what a, what a wow. All right, so then they're outside and then you move on to another baby animal in the bed.
Yes? Yeah, so to go on to, so then I have, I have 20, okay, you're not actually gonna, I have 25 dogs, but on top of the 10. So the 25 live outside, but they have, I have a shed and I rescue dogs off of the street, and from high-asian age- Jake is on board with all of this nonsense?
Yeah, I mean, I kind of like, this is like, he knows how much I like love animals, like I would like- Yeah, but you can't have all those animals- No, so we drew the line, actually, he said no more, but I have to obviously have my dog Winnie in the bed, like that's like, we're not compromising on that. Actually, he said no more, but I have to obviously have my dog Winnie in the bed. That's like, we're not compromising on that. It is a deal breaker.
But he does allow farm animals, and he enjoys it as much as I do. We just had two babies, two baby, baby puppies, neonatal puppies come to us right before Christmas, and their mom got taken away so they needed to be bottle fed. They weren't taken to the bottle. So Jake and I every four hours would tube feed these babies in an incubator.
Oh wow. I thought you were going to say that you had to bird feed them. Jason, how much? No, I actually wouldn't do that at all. But I would do a lot for animals but that is where I would do the work. Jason, do you, I'm just thinking about Jason. He can't walk on a hotel carpet unless he's got slippers on. Socks and slippers.
He's gotta walk. Can you imagine being in that? Yeah, I mean, you're there for two weeks. I would bring my slippers too. It's not crazy, but Jason, the thought of these animals in their bedroom. No, yeah. There's too many exposed bacteria ports on an animal to rub on your pillow or where other parts of your body might.
It's just, it's not, it's a clean space. I just have like, no, I do not think that. Like when I think of an animal, I am just like, like I get in my car and I'll go on Facebook I do not think that. Like I get in my car and I'll go on Facebook, because I have a fake Facebook of a different person. I go in and I see in my community if there are any stray dogs that have been left, been dumped, and then I go and I pick them up and I put them in my car and then I take them to animal control and get them registered. Then I bring them back to my house and I microchip them myself
and I vaccinate them myself. And then groom them. I give them usually their first night will be in my house. And then I build kennels outside and I have a full staff. And recently I just got my rescue license. So now I'm actually a rescue. Wow, that's incredible. But now we've found over 250 dogs home.
That is lovely. That's incredible. It breaks my heart that there is 250 dogs to be found. Actually, like in the rural parts of Georgia it's really, really bad and there's a lot of dog fighting rings, and I have a lot of that situation. I see that a lot. But Jake is amazing.
Like he loves seeing the animals come in and out. Like he'll be like, Mill, like this one comes in for 24 hours and then gets adopted the next day, or sometimes the longest, you know, some of them have been with us is like around two years. So people are aware that they can go to your whatever
to adopt? Just, yeah, just the website. Like if you want to go on the website. What's the website? What's the website? It's joey'sfriends.com and you can view the available dogs we have, all of them. J-O-E-Y?
Yeah, J-O-E-Y, joeysfriends.com. And they're all vaccinated, microchipped, fixed, house-trained, leash-trained, and crate-trained. So that's like a, yeah. Wow, I realize, if I don't find you a home, I cannot find the next one a home. So it's like the faster I find you an amazing home, the quicker I can get in my car and go and pull from another animal control
and basically lower the euthanasia list. Can I go to the natural next question, which you're welcome to say I'm not answering that. I'm sure the desire to maybe have a child yourself one day is Burns Bright, question mark? Yeah. Yes? I mean, that is like, that is been-
You're still very young. I'm still really young, but my mom actually had her first child at 21 and my dad was 19. And they, you know, it's been my thing since before I met Jake, like since I was a baby, like I told my mom, like baby dolls, like I wanted to be a mom just like the way my mom was to me and my nan, like my grandmother is like a huge,
she was a huge part of my life. And so yeah, I mean Jake knows how important it is to me and like of course I want to focus on really establishing myself as an actor and as a producer but I also find it's so important to start a family for me personally, like it's a huge thing. Jake was like, we cannot do that until we get married. So that was his thing.
And my thing was I really want a family. I really want a big family. Like I'm one of four, he's one of four. So it is definitely in our future. But for me, like I don't see having your own child, you know, as really any different in adopting. So I feel like anything's out. Because for me, like my home is full of love
for anyone and anything. And so that is what kind of we stand by, Jake and I, is our energy in the house, is the door is always open and we want everyone to feel really comfortable. I'm headed there in two weeks to start this thing with David. More than welcome. The door is open, so.
The door is unlocked. No, and so yeah, so that's kind of where we're at. We're very much like, we are always going to be, you know, wanting to start a family and it just doesn't really, it doesn't matter in what way or when, but it will happen for sure. That's so great. Well, Millie, one more time with the website. What's it called?
joey'sfriends.com. joey'sfriends.com. That's amazing. Yeah, good's amazing. Yeah, good for you. Well, your absolute delight, Millie. Yeah, you are a delight. Thank you guys.
Thank you so much. Again, please tell dad hello. I will, I'm gonna call him right now. He's gonna be very pleased to hear that you even remembered him, to be honest with you. Oh, this man, totally unforgettable. Well, have a great rest of your day. Go Bottle Feed.
And thank you very, very much for doing this. Thank you guys so much. For me it was really, really cool to meet you. I've been a fan ever since. Thank you so much guys. It's been really nice to be able to talk to you guys. It's great to see you again even though you don't remember. No, it's okay.
It'll come back to us soon. Yeah, thank you guys. I hope to see you in person. I'll be there in two weeks. All right, see you there. Exactly, bye guys, thank you. Thank you, bye, bye. Bye.
Now this is a good person. You know, this is, you know, I mean. That was really cool, like, for me. I don't know if you guys are as big of a fan as I am. By the way, she's done tons of stuff, but like, I'm a massive Stranger Things fan. The last season's coming up, I'm super excited. I've, you know, I love it.
Is there something, is there a spoiler that you were dying to ask her that she probably wouldn't have been able to answer about this final season? Well, no, you just want to know how it ends. Yeah, like why did it all happen? What was the thing in the, what's it called, the underworld?
What planet is it? What was it called? The upside down. Yeah, the upside down. Oh, you watch it too? I've seen it, yeah. It's a fantastic show. I love how cinematic it is.
All those kids are such great actors and she's amazing. Gaten Matarazzo too, he's great. He's one of the kids in the show. They're all great, by the way. They're all great. But Gaten Matarazzo was in Les Mis on Broadway as a kid. Yeah, what else Sean? Yeah, what did he do there?
Oh, he's happy with this one. Go ahead, take your time. I don't have one. You actually don't have one. I thought you did. I thought you were leaning, you were, no? No, I got one, I got one. Oh, do you?
It's gonna be bye bye birdie watch this. No, no, no. But's, but Will nailed it. One of the greatest things about Stranger Things is the upside, up, by, down, up, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, she's got dual citizenship, right? Yeah, oh God, this one? And so she's, what would you call that? Bainational! Yes!
Bain! Bainational. Bain! Smart. Less. Smart. Less. See you next time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.